dan axé mon divorce à la fin du conte
finance vous pouviez laver le linge de
vos mecs avant qu'on les récupère ça
serait sympa merci donc aux fines manger
chez moi à paris dans mon appartement
avec les trois enfants droit hier fond
et un char poste avait beaucoup
d'occupations ça se passe plutôt pas mal
je suis très occupé parce que je fais
les matinales en radio sur chérie fm
donc c'est lever tous les jours à 5h30
avec la radio à la maison ensuite à 9h
et bien les cours commencent pour les
enfants en zoom donc je suis père dix
ans et tout ça et puis après même sans
le chien imaginer des cibles et ensuite
c'est de chill un peu jusqu'à au soir je
me retrouve avec vous je dirais quand
même l'attitude de mes enfants au début
du confinement non son bien et ses
alliés et puis au fur et à mesure ils
m'ont quand même donné vachement de coup
de main quand même surtout le brandon je
suis contente et fière de lui
je leur présente dans mon quartier c'est
pas pourquoi les gens sont quand même
beaucoup dehors
après intel des bonnes raisons d'être
dehors je sais pas mais son voeux aura
plusieurs enseignes avec les vélos les
enfants et tout après chacun fait comme
il peut mais c'est vrai que ça reste
assez surprenant
je vous ai pas jamais mais je faisais
fait rarement site de sieste et saufs
honda cance et là en fait j'ai retrouvé
le plaisir de faire des siestes de temps
en temps je me fais une sieste et c'est
le preneur au coude je suis du genre
quand même pas mal à à à planter les
dîners parce que comme je me lève très
tôt
bah je suis fatigué soir et donc je
report jaugeage va lâcher en souvent je
suis contente même brandon man u
contente et je me suis dit que
j'essaierai quand même le plus planté
d'aller au restaurant quand je dis oui
je j'assume le truc je trouve pas bi
excuse pour rester chez moi est ce que
j'en ai marre de rester chez moi voilà
on est dans ma cuisine et c'est prenons
l'endroit dans lequel j'ai passé plus de
temps en ce moment puisque je cuisine
tout le temps donc voilà ma synacass-ci
italienne quand même parce qu'il faut
bien et puis j phi du poisson pour ce
soir voilà qui attend dans le pur jeu si
vous voyez c'est du bar
donc c'est ma cuisine
c'était une journal des infos de du 1er
avril
donc c'était évidemment un poisson
d'avril et c'est la journaliste de
chérie fm qu'il avait il avait écrit il
s'appelle vanessa habib et c'est très
drôle c'était une annonce aux enfants
comme quoi ils allaient reprendre
l'école et envoyé deux enfants qui
étaient au bout de leur vie en larmes
devoir aller qui rentre à l'école jean
vincent s'il veut reprendre dès demain
nous sommes allés en moi c'est très tôt
le matin et ne repartir quels amis pour
des îles pour manger comme cette fois
par an grand bassa débat en fait puisque
comme dans mon métier je dois je vais
lire forcément puisque je travaille pour
le magazine infrarouge et je suis
actrice des pages livres donc le
magazine continue et d'accra édité par
en version papier mais en version
digitale
donc je lis beaucoup pour préparer les
cépages là après je dois dire que je
suis pas contre passer un peu de temps
sur l'atrix
un verre de vin à 20h mais comment
semaine je vois pas parce que je me lève
tôt voilà radio et que boire un verre
c'est compliqué de bien boire un verre
mais j'allais avoir deux trois ans fait
donc je préfère avoir zéro un peu
abstinence en semaine et à partir du
jeudi vendredi
il ya deux trois petits lâcher
[Musique]
maintenant je regarde pas la télé du
tout sauf que le travail évidemment pour
voir avec les expertises médias
éclairage regarde voilà gelé je regarde
pas sinon été et apéro sky coude pendant
longtemps on en fait enfin j'en fais
souvent fait je fais de scrabble avec ma
mère ou de yaté avec les enfants et ma
mère voilà ça passionnant
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à faire du sport je suis
vraiment finul et j'essaye de temps en
temps mais c'est vraiment pas terrible
[Musique]
et mme blague c'est une phrase que j'ai
lu et qui m'a fait marrer
selena lac-simon divorce à la fin du
conte finance vous pouviez laver le
linge de vaud mais tellement qu'on les
récupère ce serait sympa merci